die geschichte der menschheit muss
umgeschrieben werden ja bisher waren die
ältesten knochenfunde von menschen also
dem homo sapiens 195000 jahre alt von
sieben alter unserer spezies ging die
wissenschaft bisher aus doch nun wurden
menschliche fossilien in marokko
entdeckt die viel älter sind 300.000
jahre
was das für die forschung und unsere art
bedeutet jetzigen klick zum
seitenwechsel herzlich willkommen
eigentlich stammt die fundstelle aus den
sechziger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts doch was dort damals
gefunden wurde
darauf konnten sich die forscher keinen
reim machen die funde wurden auf ein
alter von 40.000 jahren geschätzt aber
waren so primitiv und waren eher nach
einer art neandertaler aus jacques
hublin wollte dem auf den grund gehen
doch als er sich die fundstelle marokko
in den neunzigerjahren ansah die level i
wrote höhle war das ziemlich
enttäuschend sie war komplett
verschüttet
es gab keine möglichkeit für ihn dort zu
graben mögliche funde waren viel zu tief
unter geröll vergraben übrigen gab auf
doch ganz verließ ihn nicht der mut 2004
wurde er in die max planck gesellschaft
aufgenommen und hatte wohl erstmal zeit
und geld um an diesem ort wieder zu
graben doch erstmals musste die höhle
freigelegt werden 200 kubikmeter geröll
musste sein team mit einem bulldozer
wegräumen bis der zugang wieder frei
warf und dann gelangen den forscherinnen
und forschern dort die weiteren
sensationellen fundes immer wieder
beeindruckt welche bahnbrechenden
erkenntnisse die wissenschaft heute mit
modernen methoden erlangen kann gerade
war es noch der stammbaum der
dinosaurier
wer bisher einfach falsch war und jetzt
ist es auch unsere eigene spezies die
betroffen ist fliegt sie viel länger auf
der erde wie bisher gedacht statt rund
200.000 jahren existiert der mensch rund
100000 jahre länger nämlich rund 300.000
jahren mindestens 187 hat sich das thema
gewünscht dass am mittwoch für furore
sorgte die funde konnten so exakt
kartiert werden weil die forscher und
forscherinnen auf eine gruppe von fünf
menschen gestoßen waren
die offenbar ihre werkzeuge engst hatten
das erlaubte dem team vom leipziger
max-planck-institut für evolutionäre
anthropologie eine weitaus genauere
datierung der kunde mittels des per mini
fans verfahren bei dem die anzahl von
elektronen gemessen wird die im laufe
der jahrtausende durch radioaktive
strahlung freigesetzt werden und sich
anhäufen und das ergebnis von 14 messung
seines zweiten teams um shannon
mcpherron und daniel richter bahn
verblüffen
die funde sind 315.000 jahre alt und
damit setzt sich das puzzle der menschen
funde aus afrika ganz neu zusammen es
scheint nicht den einen ort dort als
wiege der menschheit zu geben sondern
vielmehr scheinen sich auf dem ganzen
kontinent
die verschiedenen modernen ausprägung
die gewicht gehören und so weiter des
homo sapiens entwickelt und sich dann
dort langsam über die verschiedenen
gruppen zum heutigen homo sapiens
verbunden zu haben eine lange und
komplexe entwicklung in berlin glaubt es
hat dass der mensch noch viel älter ist
er vermutet ein alter von fast einer
halben million jahre
jetzt will er in der höhle weiter graben
und hofft auf weitere erkenntnisse wenn
es dazu neues gibt dann erfahrt ihr
natürlich hier tut mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht gehen auf die
glocke beim verpasst hier garantiert
kein video ansonsten gestand blatter